may I ask you about your return to the
Tonight Show
yes Jimmy Fallon that must have been a
seminal moment yeah and I'm going on
again in a sit down position this
Thursday so yeah it was great
they invited me back it was the first
time well you know I was banned from the
Tonight Show
right forever and Jimmy you I've done
The Late Late Show I think he just said
that's stupid bring it back she is that
tonight shoulder since I am certainly
part of the history only woman only
permanent guest host ever had never had
one after me if you notice letter never
took a day off you learned and so it was
very moving when they called me they
said come on and what was it like to
actually amazing well first of all I
left to say I'm which 28 years ago it
was still there but it was very
emotional and then you see some of the
crew that is still there and it was I
had much history going on enough as
nothing and came out literally Carson
said you gonna be a star
so it was a huge thing huge list of what
was it like to kind of watch your mom
because you know you know some of what
you had to deal with and kind of being
banished from the Tonight Show and
talking to her about it to see her be
back well it's interesting because
people always talk about like there was
this big huge and it was a sound but in
the moment it wasn't like we sat around
all the time she's been banned from the
Tonight Show it was never really part of
our daily lexicon but when they said you
know coming on it was more exciting that
she was gonna be on the first night a
foul it right when he took over the
tonight chef and then suddenly you
realized oh my god this was such a
seminal it was almost a backlash we
didn't really think about it that much
in advance there's no master plan it
just worked and then you realize the
emotion of it how much amazing and
people caught on to it immediately
Rosabelle we didn't think anybody was
even gonna put number one two together